in general email but tonight at the casa
phone ago I had to go talk set a you
look for hard when him first and only at
the blogger at Everton had polyatomic
others they will obsessed
[Music]
it's yoshiya hey Betina to remit and
postcolonial in our banana
[Music]
hi i'm helen and and i coordinate the
specialist network that advises doctors
from around the EU on the management of
rare forms of epilepsy this can be very
difficult as epilepsy can be caused by
many different rare diseases this was
the case with only the Finnish boy his
doctor came to our network to ask for
advice biscuit really honest fall in our
ears Merida special network first for
epilepsy as for epilepsy Peru the poem
is feelings enthralled alanna ubach con
una semana iranian padam des her
presence astronomy so Callaghan Magnus
for the best altitude
Milgram Germany not skill made for next
risk for Harlem opium hosts shanks till
year effect Africa Tomas a different
Rica Yama's epileptologist parvissimus
mazzaglia's a him Italian medium a smoky
sadistically kiss to gamma knife
principal stroke therapies of this the
Spaniards Murphy's Olympia's
it and upon semantically - no Nina
Borden attack Slab City after symphonies
and nostalgic you a religious debate
analysis facility semi analytical all at
the domain DiSpirito sister Nora patella
knee on knee
Alexei harvester tsuyama resist uppity
Rasta Yolanda Shane and Cyrus 60-person
aqua air open union in epilepsy Hacienda
de Burgos tota
whose team el tamaño Nia
Oh tomorrow Mugen ASEAN to the other
area Oh mais de corn in dopamine
Americanism Matta Lake Austin del Este
reading over an iconic court of thought
we had a net worth of austin para plaza
very costa novel la la hermana looser
agua para hacer across la carrera good
colors with 12 ampere Hamilton Hadouken
[Music]
nice to meet you and it's lovely to see
that we could help your son anti-realist
yeah no problem at all
it's fantastic we could do that oh my
goodness we got the whole family hello
who are you doing well
[Music]
you